so in this video I want to talk about
the light reactions the photosynthesis
which include this idea of the Z scheme
which we'll get to shortly and of course
this whole process is
photophosphorylation because we're going
to make ATP that is going to be powered
by light so we're checking taking water
and turning it into oxygen so that's an
oxidation reaction and then we have
nadp+ being reduced to NADPH that's
another thing that we've said so we're
going to have this occur in the light
reactions and that of course is going to
be coupled to the production of ATP so
we have nadp+ we turn NADPH and water
being turned into being split into
protons and oxygen that of course is
coupled to the production of ATP I'm
going through this really really quickly
because this is just the general
overview
this whole thing is accomplished by
these two photosystems photosystems 2
and photosystem 1 so what does the over
overall process look like so we have
photosystem 2 is where water is split
into oxygen and the protons where does
this happen
this happens in the thylakoid lumen okay
and this is important you'll notice I
put this little pink star next ed if
next to it I'll get to that just a
second this happens in the thylakoid
lumen and the reason why that's
important I'll explain more once we get
to the Z scheme but keep this in mind
for now so where are the electrons going
from into the electrons are going of
course from from water right initially
to will later see this thing called
cytochrome b6f
okay so that's really anything in that
region is considered photosystem ii
which you might see a little bit
differently in the way I draw the C
scheme but keep this in mind so then we
have after photosystem 2 we have this
thing called plastocyanin which is a
soluble protein and what this does is
really just it carries electrons from
photosystem 2 to photosystem 1 it's
basically the the middleman of the of
the entire process after plastocyanin of
course comes photosystem 2 excuse me
photosystem 1 sorry
the one so after plus a sign-in we have
photosystem one and in photosystem one
electrons go from this p700 which I'll
talk about in just a moment P 700 with
little star next to it and excited P 700
and I'll talk about what this is in just
a second to ferredoxin which is
abbreviated often as FD and then to
flavo protein which is fa d we'll see
you later
and from there of course to nadp+ to
make NADPH now it's important to know
where this happens this happens in the
stroma and again I haven't talked about
the details of why that's important just
yet but this thing and this thing are
important to keep in mind and all these
three things that I've started here they
all contribute to establishing a
particular gradient that gradient of
course is the proton gradient or the pH
gradient and I'll talk about more
details in just a second once we get to
the Z scheme so now what's important to
realize is that this overall process
right is you know taking this nadp+ --is
we're adding a proton to it and making
it and of course electrons to make it
NADPH how many how many electrons are we
adding to nadp+ in this proton to make
an ad pH well if I know that nadp+ is
going to add a hydrogen right in the
form of a proton this overall charge is
positive 2 right from these 2 positive
charges here and the overall NADPH is
neutral so what do I how many electrons
would I have to add in order to make
this neutral 2 electrons right two
negative charges to balance out these
two positive charges and water of course
is oxidized to oxygen and two protons
and of course the two electrons hop off
there so the overall process again is
this so again these aren't crazy details
that I find too important what I do want
you to realize is that the overall
process
it has a delta G of positive 220
kilojoules per mole which is a huge
positive number what does that mean that
means that these light reactions are
endergonic right they require energy
they are not spontaneous okay how is
this process driven if it needs energy
where is that end usually come from well
from light okay light energy drives this
process how let's go to the Z scheme so
now this is kind of a mess right now but
you'll see what's going to go down in
just a second okay so in the Z scheme
this is what's important to recognize is
first of all this thing that looks like
a mess but I'm going to try my best to
make sense of it if you sort of turn
your head to the left you can kind of
see from here you have this little Z
shape going there there there that's why
it's called a z scheme looks kind of
like an N if you're looking at it
straight but whatever what's supposed to
happen this is a bunch of all these
different things that I've drawn here
right are complexes along the thylakoid
membrane and that's important to keep in
mind I'll fill in all these little
blanks here and hopefully it'll make a
lot of sense but basically the Z scheme
is well what's happening here is the
flow of electrons so if you notice I
have these gray arrows all these gray
arrows have a little electron above them
that's basically where the electrons are
flowing to what you should keep in mind
is that I've drawn this here this energy
going upwards so basically any step
that's going upwards is increasing enter
in energy which means it requires energy
anything going down any arrows going
down are steps that you know our
exergonic that we're releasing energy so
in the Z scheme these ones going down
are extra guy like these ones going up
are endergonic exergonic endergonic
exergonic so let's go through and kind
of figure this out the first thing that
we have is we're starting off with water
and we're splitting it into oxidizing it
to oxygen and of course protons okay so
now what's important here is that we're
releasing these protons into the
environment so this is going to
contribute to the proton gradient well
where is this happening but what we want
to keep in mind is that we want a high
concentration on one side and a low
concentration on the other side so for
taking this water and splitting it these
protons where are they going well they
are going this is happening in the
thylakoid lumen okay which means that
what we're going to be doing here is
we're going to be building up a hydrogen
ion concentration gradient a quart
between the lumen and the stroma where
the thylakoid lumen is supposed to have
a high H+ concentration and the stroma
will have a low one so this manganese
sort of complex here what it does is
it's often called the oxygen-evolving
complex so this manganese complex is
called the oxygen-evolving complex which
I'm just going to reavie 8as OAC but
basically it allows oxygen to evolve
from water okay so the electrons are
given up from water to this manganese
protein and then they go from this
manganese protein to this Z complex here
and then eventually they go to this
thing that's p680 what this p680 is
basically it's this is chlorophyll okay
so you probably have heard of
chlorophyll before we're talking about
chloroplast chlorophyll is a pigment
which what makes the plant green and
these chlorophylls have particular
photosynthetic units and these
photosynthetic units have these things
called reaction centers what's important
to get from that is that the light
energy reacts at a particular reaction
center there's a particular location
within the photos that hakuna on the
core fill that reacts or responds to
light so
this reason that I've drawn this yellow
arrow here is that this is actually
light energy coming in so this is light
energy coming in to this p680 and the
reason why it's p680 is because this the
wavelength of light that's actually
coming in is 680 nanometers which is
what this chlorophyll responds to so why
is this light here coming in well I
mentioned earlier that any downward
electrons as a chum flow is spontaneous
and doesn't require energy right but if
we're going from p680 once p680 has
these electrons it wants to keep those
electrons it wants to stay reduced so in
order to oxidize it it's going to
require energy so we have to have an
input of energy that input of energy
comes from light and once we add that
light p680 is and it's in its excited
state so this this green green star here
indicates excited so now this
chlorophyll reaction center carrying
those electrons is emits excited so once
we have this excited state by the way
and one thing I didn't mention earlier
is that everything bound to this left
side of these brackets is typically
considered part of photosystem 2 and
then to the right side of this bracket
is considered photosystem 1 now I will
mention though that sometimes the
sometimes this bracket will extend to
include cytochrome b6f as far to and
everything before as part of photosystem
1 because the class of sign is often
considered the mediator between the two
photosystems just keep that in mind
anyway once this excited p680
photosynthetic unit is excited once it's
excited the electrons go to FeO fightin
and then from FeO fighting to
plastoquinone and then plastic window
undecided chrome b6f now plastoquinone
is interesting because what it does is
it takes protons from the stroma and
dump and pumps them into the lumen so
here we have protons from the stroma and
their palm
over to the thylakoid lumen so notice I
wrote this number two here there was a
number one right here this these these
things written in these pink numbers
here represent the ways in which a
proton gradient is established so plasto
quinone pumps protons from the stroma
into the thylakoid lumen so this is the
second second time we've seen a
contribution to the proton gradient then
what do we have going on here then we
have these electrons continuing to flow
down there down this scheme here towards
+ of sign in and then to p700 one thing
I want to mention before I talk about
p700 further is that notice that
anything that you consider between feyo
fighting and you know this p700 here if
I asked you which has a higher reduction
potential plus of sign in Orfeo fightin
well which one is further down the chain
plus of sign in which means plus of sign
in' wants to get reduced more than fail
fightin does which means that plus of
sign it would have a higher reduction
potential so keep that in mind for
anything you know along this chain okay
reduction potentials play a role here so
now once we get to this p700 again this
p700 is very much like this p680 and
that it does not want to give up its
electrons so in order to cause that to
happen you have to have light energy
come in right and of course is b700
because the wavelength of light that
this reaction Center responds to is 700
nanometers so then we have this excited
p 700 so the excited p 700 will give up
its electrons to ferredoxin and then
throw dachshund will give them to this F
ID or display well protein here and then
with this flava protein does is it takes
nadp+ plus protons and of course these
electrons here to make NADPH so now
notice what's going on here is that
these protons here
are being used up right so we're
lowering the concentration of H+ is here
well where do we want to lower the H+
concentration in the stroma right so we
would expect this process to happen in
the stroma so this is the third thing
that actually contributes to
establishing the proton gradient okay
so what do we net here the overall
result here is we have a high
concentration of protons in the lumen
and a low h+ concentration in the stroma
so this is our net sort of proton
gradient here so that's the z scheme now
notice about the z scheme is that many
of the steps are actually exergonic
write all these downward arrows they're
extra ionic steps there are only two
endergonic steps right this step here
and this step here but those are so
endergonic that the overall process
despite the fact that there are
exergonic steps the entire process
overall is endergonic okay because of
these two steps that require light
energy
so now let's get another view of what's
going on in the chloroplasts so what's
happening really so we have photosystem
ii here right and then plastic quinone
we set it from be 6f plus a sign in
photosystem one ferredoxin F ID of the
flava protein which is called ferredoxin
nadp+ oxidoreductase because its
oxidizing ferredoxin right it's getting
it to lose its electrons and it's
reducing nadp+ to nadph so what's
happening here why do we care about this
so first of all let me just fill this in
here this is of course light energy
coming in at these two different photo
systems but what's happening we have the
establishing of this proton gradient so
we mentioned here that we have in the
thylakoid space with the thylakoid lumen
we have the first thing that contributes
it's splitting water right that
increases the hydrogen ion concentration
in the thylakoid space or lumen
the other thing the second thing was
what happens at plastoquinone i takes
protons from the stroma right from the
outside from the stroma into the
thylakoid space static white lumen okay
so then we have this buildup of protons
in here with a bunch of protons in the
thylakoid space and i can actually go
through and just you know draw a bunch
of these things right we have a bunch of
a bunch in here we have a few out here
right but most of them are of course in
the thylakoid space static white Goodman
so that's the second thing right pasta
quinone is the second thing that
contributes to the proton gradient and
of course the third thing up here right
is when nadp+
uses up these na or when n DV plus picks
up these protons these protons are now
bound to nadp+ to make NADPH right so
they're there concentration outside in
the stroma is decreasing so we have this
relative difference between the lumen
the stroma where we have a high
concentration of H pluses in here right
and a low concentration of h+ is out of
the stroma so what happens in the
chloroplast very it's a very similar
process to what happens in the electron
transport chain where do these protons
want to go they want to flow
spontaneously down their concentration
gradient so they want to go back out to
the stroma but they can't they need a
particular channel protein so that that
will allow them to do that so that
channel protein is ATP synthase okay now
it's a little bit different than then
the mitochondria is ATP synthase because
there's probably slight differences in
structure there's still a channel
portion called the FO specifically the
CFO C stands for chloroplast and then of
course the C f1 which is the actual ATP
synthase so what this does is it couples
right the the flow of these protons out
out of the the lumen back into the
stroma and that spontaneous flow
releases energy that releases that
released energy is harnessed to power
the phosphor
tune of ADP to make ATP that's
essentially it so that's pretty much the
light reactions I hope that video is
helpful I do want to mention one quick
thing in case some of the names that I
mentioned we're a little bit tough to
spell or to see I think I wrote them
down over here somewhere yeah so there's
a little slide notes here the FeO fight
in is spelled like this at least I think
so plastic windows build like this pcs
plastocyanin FD is Rio dachshund so
those are just little side notes there I
hope that helps clear things up and of
course I imagine that you have to pause
this video and figure things out as you
go along draw things but I hope this
video was helpful thanks for watching